you think they could have gotten the
rights to Mike Tyson's like the hardest
boss in any NES game
everybody this is my ready player one
spoiler talk honestly I didn't plan on
doing this and I was like if ever there
was a movie to do it it'd be this one
there's a lot to talk about a lot to
unpack a lot of references to reference
I'm not gonna talk about all the
references callbacks and knobs that
would be impossible I'm not saying no
one's gonna do that I'm saying there
will be videos that do that and to them
I say congratulations your team did a
great job I have no team I'm just me so
I'm gonna talk about some of the things
I like that's a solid spoiler warning if
you haven't seen ready player one well
don't necessarily watch this less you
want some spoilers I'm just saying
you've been warned really at its core
this movie is the youth fights the
corporation they have to stick it to the
man it's also a message for hey
government organizations companies just
keep your [ __ ] out of our [ __ ] you [ __ ]
this world up well enough let's just let
us have ours but in the great Easter egg
hunt the first one comes from the
racetrack that's right there I was like
that's DeLorean as the Batmobile was
KITT the Knight Rider car there I don't
know I know the DeLorean had kind of a
KITT light in the front but King Kong
was really wrecking some folks after
meeting the hottest game chick ever
which is she's really that's a hot game
jack but just funny when she's all sexy
DUP and he's like I'm in love with you
which I really didn't buy it and buy the
romances much but she's like I don't
look like this you're gonna be
disappointed then he meets her it's like
yeah you're still cute I mean terms of
big reveal there are a lot of people
still crying from the AOL Instant
Messenger of yesteryear a lot of reveals
people have experience in life is it's
not like this guy needs to get nev and
max on the case in a world where
catfishing is real I'm sure they'd be
like go home you're drunk it's it's fine
but in his hot game girl became cute
normal girl and I think he's going to be
okay but the first key is found because
he is a huge fan boy of this guy who
created this world led by Mark Rylance
which I didn't give him enough props in
my review that dude is so good I just
feel like when he's talking I'm like
that's the embodiment of the person who
would make this world but he's like if
you go backwards in the race you'll
solve the puzzle which I don't know how
no one thought of that before in a world
of trial and error I know if I'm looking
for all the paths I have in a racing
game somewhere in my life been like what
if you start backwards good nope it's
not that at all but no one ever thought
that that's like racing game Easter Egg
101 but again that world is very big
it's not just a racing game I do want to
know how no one knows when someone does
something now is it like breath of the
wild where someone can look from another
racetrack and be like hey how do you get
there let's trace it I feel
the big douchebag corporation a a
metaphor in this movie would have some
sort of software that records everything
that happened somehow I don't know again
they're probably failsafe in a cyber
world that's kind of superseding the
real world at that point
I do love when Ben Mendelsohn's
character was talking to the kid you
like he actually knows a lot about these
video games of pop culture nobody
doesn't you got someone his ear telling
him the information that's just how
those companies I was just a beautiful
representation of that corporate
disconnect but our heroes being read
they realize hey there's signing that's
where it is that's where the next key is
and I dude when that shining scene came
on you could hear the theater gasping
it's like a bunch of cinephiles and
critics alike oh that was made
constructed and tailored for movie
critics but again if I'm picking [ __ ]
apart in a world where obviously there
are a lot of people who play this a lot
of people who like video games a lot of
people who probably like movie salsa no
one ever said hey you can experience the
shining let's do that with some friends
at that point when you go into that room
and you see some lady dancing with
zombies you're gonna be like something's
off about that I feel like I should I
should approach that that's happened to
me with games I'm like something's off
about that thing so I'm going to
investigate more oh look at that it
unlocked a shrine judging by all the
companies guys who were screaming in
horror you see them all dying when
they're trying to do this shining
challenge maybe not a lot of people
would even want to try I personally feel
like it would be fun to experience VR
Oasis style horror I bring my Chucky
doll along I just throw it at the
zombies which is probably my single
favorite laugh out loud moment in here
if I'm kind of getting ahead of myself
right now at the very end when it's an
onslaught nostalgia bomb war and that
Chucky doll flies at the camera that guy
goes oh is [ __ ] Chucky you see the
facility and everyone's turning red
because this chucky doll is just
bouncing around everyone killing them I
have a shangri-la amazing so let's
assume our crew of heroes are the only
ones who tugged on the shining thread in
a world where you could go into the
shining world they get the second case
then Ben Mendelsohn's like alright let's
just kill his shitty family anyway it
wasn't really attached to the family at
all when they blew up I was like
Congrats kid I feel like your life is
just a little better for it even says
with all the ire he can muster he's like
you killed my mom sister it's just not
the same you forgot her shitty abusive
alcoholic drunk boyfriend I did know
that character what was H I did know the
big dude was a lady then the voice is
like she could be
man you do know I'm like it feels like
year probably not a dude just like
you're hiding your voice somehow but
among getting the third key that is when
[ __ ] gets real that's when they have Ben
Mendelsohn's character at gunpoint when
he gets out of his video is he's not in
the real world and the one thing I
thought was like I have seen that before
Star Trek insurrection did that didn't
last long there either the episode
ship-in-a-bottle from Star Trek The Next
Generation also did that and that I
think is the best representation of that
point is I was like I've seen it I was
always cool when I see it because why
would you not do that at a saying it
doesn't change the fact that we saw a
hadouken o hadouken happened in here
it's gotta be one of the top three
fighting game moves of all time right
top three I mean probably it's number
one my friends and I were quantifying
the the most famous and influential
moves of all time special moves not
counting fatalities hadouken from Street
Fighter scorpion spear from Mortal
Kombat or Van dem spear depending on
what you want to call it depending on
what area you come from and Falcon punch
from Super Smash Brothers special props
to the Dragon Punch also from Street
Fighter since four down forward punch
resulting in an upward punch would be a
mechanic seen in fighting games for
decades afterwards not only did we get
Mechagodzilla but we got mecha godzilla
vs. Gundam I mean I've never seen Gundam
in my life so I'm not gonna posture like
I have not really I know everything
about it because I absolutely don't but
I do recognize the things I see it a lot
and the audience was eating that [ __ ] up
is what I like about this it's fun to
make hot toys displays or collectibles
on your shelf and have them interact
with each other in a way that you would
never see on screen but in this movie in
some form we did that's sweet
celebration that fight was pretty solid
though that Mechagodzilla scene was real
other than the fact the Iron Giant just
blowing people away which I feel like
the Iron Giant had more weapons in the
movie The Iron Giant he never really
used him Iron Giant was a weapon so
there were a lot of weapons on why
weren't those weapons pulled out I don't
know I felt like that would have been a
really good match for Mechagodzilla but
yeah crawl that's what I'm talking about
in my review I said there is a scene a
throwback a nod a reference where I was
like I didn't expect that because the
weapon is rad and that's the glaive from
crawl that the thing that star that he
throws and that's the glade cool is
weapon ever who's controlling Bros rad
I'm care what anyone says
that sounds scared the [ __ ] out of me as
a kid and I was like wire lobsters
popping out of their heads
serenity made an appearance though any
time she makes an appearance it's real I
wish they used serenity more though
rather than just
drop off the crowd running towards the
battlezone Matt I saw Battletoads I saw
Ninja Turtles I saw two Tinley pretty
sure I saw Sonya Blade Ninja Turtles
though that I was like you could have
gone for another model of Ninja Turtles
if I'm being realistic three decades
from now do you really think we're all
gonna reflect on those Ninja Turtles and
be like that those are the
quintessential Ninja Turtles and
sidenote I would not hate it if
NetherRealm Studios actually did a ninja
turtles tournament fighter game just and
put it out there don't ones searching
for the third key when they were like
okay Atari 2600 Scott Abbi I was like
all right we're going to see adventure
that's just the way this is gonna go
down I didn't know the third key would
actually be in adventure that would
venture heavily deals with keys had
nothing to do with those keys but all I
know is what anyone says Atari 2600 game
I'm like adventure the best one it was
so rad so I was glad that they actually
had adventure fee the big things though
there is a reason that it was like oh
there's Easter Egg that's an adventure I
learned about pretty recently it's not
about winning the game is about playing
the game but also winning does anyone
really become a famous YouTube gamer
twitch streamer video gamer in general
because you played but never won I feel
like winning matters at a point
I did love TJ Miller's characters a
mercenary of some sort which I do have
to wonder as I can he just kill people
that aren't engaged with him in combat
does he have to be part of a game part
of a mission or can you just literally
go to anybody just blow them away I mean
in legacy of kain as you go through with
the Soul Reaver and just wipeout people
in town I felt like a dick about it but
for some reason I did it you don't just
blow off steam and a shooter be like I
gotta blow off steam and just kill
people so what you're doing in Call of
Duty you're killing people but there are
rules everyone in Call of Duty is there
to kill and be killed if you're just
hanging out at a nightclub in this
virtual world can someone just kill you
I feel like natural selection style all
the [ __ ] will just kill off all the
nice people and you'd have a big combat
zone everywhere I guess that's unnatural
selection still breather you die nice or
you adapt and become another [ __ ] who
can fight off the other [ __ ] now it's
not a dark night reference it's just
reality
I do call [ __ ] on any online game
having an attainable super bomb that
will wipe out every user in the game
that's is that what I mean from my
recollection that's what this bomb did
it killed every user in the game and it
was completely acquirable
no you imagine if Blizzard had that in
Warcraft someone could actually get a
super bomb all right BAM everyone's dead
because someone would get it and someone
would use it maybe the bomb is so
expensive it's only at
aníbal through companies and
corporations in which case that's just a
recipe for disaster
you mean the sweet old man who
apparently wants people to experience
his nostalgic brain and escape their
reality and come into a reality that
he's crafted that's probably better than
the other reality and it's just an
escape for everybody to create a device
that would blow everyone up in it I love
how a lot of reviews I've read or seen
about this movie a lot of people are
like I didn't know as much about the
real world I want to know more about the
real world I wanted to know more about
how the online world worked I can give a
[ __ ] about the real world I did love
with TJ Miller's like well I thought you
were bluffing man that's a total camper
move too we are heading towards a future
where terms like camp that's a camper
move and other online gaming insults are
actually going to be the insults of the
time so the bomb is used wipes everyone
out then Wade Watts comes back because
Ask Jeeves gave him a free live and then
he wins and everyone's super happy but
at that point is he's just like a god
compared to every other user because
they all lost their care but he didn't
pretty sweet deal but in the end dude
gets the easter egg this is where I
would have failed even if I had solved
everything and got the Easter egg at a
point where the wizard it's like here's
sign here I'd be like I guess I have to
you know legally speaking I would think
the riddles are over what would have
happened if he had done it but like I'm
sorry you signed the legal piece of
paper that seems perfectly logical that
you have to do I'm gonna put that in my
magical pocket and you can go ahead and
[ __ ] off my company will I don't go to
second place what would have happened I
feel like there could be a strong
argument for like no no you said all I
had to do was get the Easter egg and I
got it it was nothing about another
challenge also your clues Easter eggs
and your keys are obvious as [ __ ] that's
in the end ready player one like I said
before was a great time I know there are
a lot of references I didn't actually
talk about because there's so many I
mean they're just kind of doing a flyby
at this point how much can you actually
recall this is actually this movie
should be a recollection test it's
difficult it's hard and that's why
recollection tests they're actually a
real test you could take if it were easy
or normal to do so there wouldn't be
tests the point is these are some of the
things I like is one that gets it the
glaive honestly I want to tell you about
the glaive as the point of this video
talk about the glaive and then filler
I hope the filler was worth it for here
but I'll ask you again ready player one
have you now seen it now that it's out
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see any more
[Music]